bonjour claude lelouch maison merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france ce soir
dans le fond qu'est ce que vous retenez
d'élocution de la lumière poutine cet
après midi je crois que votre sujet a
très bien montré vladimir poutine a
voulu envoyer trois messages en réalité
à la population russe
le premier message est que la vie et la
santé des citoyens c'est plus important
que le reste est à ce titre il a en
effet décidé de reporter la consultation
populaire sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
il n'y a pas de date fixée pour ce
report ce sont les spécialistes les
médecins les scientifiques qui
proposeront les dates et il n'y a pas
d'urgence d'ailleurs puisque les
sciences des élections législatives et
que pour l'année prochaine deuxième
message nécessité de faire preuve de
cohésion et une solidarité pour endiguer
la propagation du coronavirus et là en
effet devenir poutine a pris de décision
cette semaine de congé avec maintien des
salaires payés par les entreprises
et puis une autre mesure pour financer
toutes les mesures économiques et
sociales qui est de taxer les revenus
qui sont générés à l'étranger et de les
taxer à hauteur de l'impôt sur le revenu
des personnes physiques c'est-à-dire de
13%
parce qu'il faut bien financer ces
mesures dans le budget d'autant plus
qu'actuellement
le cours du pétrole est très bon état à
peu près à 25 dollars le baril troisième
message est bien le troisième message
c'est en effet soutenir les classes
moyennes et préserver l'activité
économique
alors à ce titre il a énuméré
dans le détail de cinq mesures de
caractère social votre sujet ans en a
mentionné quelques unes donc je ne
reviendrai pas et aussi des mesures à
caractère familial par exemple
l'allocation de 5000 euros
supplémentaires par mois par enfant pour
les familles qui ont déjà droit à la
question femme idéale pour les pour les
enfants et puis le fait
les indemnités qui seront versées aux
chômeurs et aux salariés en congé
maladie ne pourront pas être inférieur
au salaire minimum général c'est à dire
12 mille roubles par mois
le gouvernement par ailleurs propose un
dispositif de report et de
rééchelonnement des remboursements des
prêts consentis aux particuliers soutien
aux pme alors ça je crois que c'est un
point majeur dans les propositions de
vanille abouti il ya au moins quatre
mesures report du paiement de l'impôt et
des cotisations sociales report de six
mois des remboursements de crédits
bancaires moratoire sur les déclarations
de faillite ce qui est évidemment très
important
et puis réduction de 15 % des
cotisations sociales il a d'ailleurs dit
que cette mesure est peut-être d'autres
pourraient subsister ensuite et de venir
et devenir pérenne voilà pour
l'essentiel vous ce qu'il faut retenir
je crois de la delà de l'intervention de
la dmr poutine ce matin face blanche
maison est ce que ces mesures a lancé
vous semblent suffisantes pour lutter
contre le coc u19
quand la plupart des pays ont déjà
adopté le confinement le confinement
strict pardon écoutez c'est frappant que
le maire de moscou monsieur sergueï
sobianine et estimé hier dans un débat
télévisé à moscou que probablement le
nombre des personnes atteintes par le
ver issus des russes étaient
sous-estimés et il a aussi appelé à un
confinement plus sérieux vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que le nombre des
victimes approchait 700 ce qui est très
peu pour une population de 145 à 150
millions d'habitants
et puis à très peu de morts tant mieux
tant mieux mais peut-être est-il aussi
un problème de comptabilisation des des
résultats de la contamination par ce run
un virus alors le maire de moscou n'est
pas le seul d'ailleurs a estimé que les
chiffres sont sous-évalués et qu'il faut
prendre des mesures plus sévères
aujourd'hui ce qu'a dit vladimir poutine
c'est que il
j'espère que la population russe fera
preuve de responsabilité qu'elle se
confinera effectivement pendant les huit
jours de congés payés par l'entreprise
entre samedi prochain et le dimanche 5
avril
mais il est bien possible que le 5 avril
monsieur poutine doit faire une nouvelle
évaluation de la situation ce qui serait
bien normal et en fonction de cette
évaluation avec les spécialistes il
pourrait aussi décider de nouvelles
mesures peut-être plus directive
on peut noter aussi que le fait de pas à
corte leur sa fête de pâque russe et le
19 avril et peut-être certaines mesures
devront elles être prolongée jusqu'au 19
avril
alors aujourd'hui la tonalité générale
de la lumière protéine était une
allitération il s'est un peu comporter
en bon père de la nation en protecteur
et pas du tout en quelqu'un qui chercha
à punir tous une raison pour hulot en
tout cas il a fait sauter le verrou de
du référendum du 22 avril
ce qui est très important puisque
beaucoup d'observateurs des journalistes
pensaient qu'il était très réticent sur
ce point merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
claude blanchemaison d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir sur rtl rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales
merci beaucoup de votre expertise